[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau rendez vous du 7 8
sociétés et ce soir nous parlons de la
grève dans les écoles 75% des grévistes
et une école sur 2 fermée ce jeudi 13
janvier ce sont les chiffres annoncés
par les syndicats enseignants des
associations de parents d'élèves appelle
les parents à ne pas envoyer leurs
enfants à l'école après une semaine et
demie de reprise des cours la situation
sanitaire ce temps à l'école et un appel
à la grève a été lancé alors quelles
sont les raisons de cette colère on en
parle avec nos invités bertrand mesure
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
cosecrétaire du snuipp-fsu
78,1 syndicat de professeurs des écoles
cécile ribéry tel bonsoir
vous êtes la présidente de l'ape et
conflans sainte honorine associations de
parents d'élèves et muriel beaufils
bonsoir bonsoir nous est administratrice
de la fcpe une association parents
d'élèves là aussi alors dans l'académie
de versailles au 6 janvier le rectorat
dénombré 1800 une classe fermée près de
7000 cas positifs chez les élèves près
de 500 au sein du personnel bertrand
mesure c'est des chiffres qui expliquent
une situation compliquée
bah oui il est plus que compliquée elle
est au delà de tout contrôler ça fait
maintenant près quatre à cinq semaines
que nos collègues n'ont pas pu exercer
leur mission d'enseignement correctement
auprès des élèves dont ils ont la charge
les entrées et les sorties des uns et
des autres les protocoles tous plus
inapplicable les cinq les autres malmène
le système éducatif et nos collègues
sont vraiment au bout du rouleau
la totalité des syndicats enseignants
appellent à la grève c'est inédit
bah c'est inédit mais je crois que c'est
la mesure de l'exaspération
de nos collègues qui n'arrivent plus à
accepter que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale continue à faire comme si la
réalité n'était pas quelque chose dont
il devait tenir compte qu'il s'en
affranchit en permanence il met en place
des protocoles inapplicable il malmène à
la fois les personnels les parents et
les enfants et aux trop c'est trop et
tout le monde n'en peut plus oui ce
protocole sanitaire il a été annoncé
donc par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale la jeunesse et des sports il a
été après allégée par le premier
ministre le 10 janvier dernier muriel
beaufils la fcpe soutient le mouvement
des professeurs c'est le syndicat c'est
l'association pardon de parents d'élèves
qui demandent à ce que les parents ne
dépose pas les enfants dans les
établissements ce jeudi tout à fait
absolument c'est sami vivons mais je
confirme les propos de monsieur mesure
nous vivons une situation inédite est
innaceptable qui est maintenant
incontrôlable depuis noël trois
protocoles sanitaires ont été mis en
place donc avant nous l enfant pourrait
revenir avec un test négatif ou un pcr
qui devait être montré à la rentrée il
fallait qu'il fasse un test pcr au g20
dont qu un test anti génie qui devait
être montré puis deux autres tests et
puis aujourd'hui 3 autotests suffisent
avec l'attestation sur l'honneur des
parents et les autres tests sont
toujours donnés gratuitement et l'enfant
ne sera plus en contact pendant sept
jours dont il ya du mieux mais il ya
encore des choses à faire et donc c'est
très important que pour manifester
le mouvement est aussi soutenu par la
pub de conflans sainte honorine madame
river
oui on nous
nous partageons
l'ensemble des constats clairement il
suffit d'avoir des enfants scolarisés
pour
voir quelles l embarras et jeu et c'est
un mot bien faible sur le terrain et la
la la la la désorganisation totale
par le fait que que subissent les
différents acteurs du terrain donc
on a eu a beau avoir des protocoles
allégé il ya encore beaucoup de choses
qui ne fonctionnent pas il n'y a pas de
tout est dans les pharmacies il n'y a
pas de ya pas de formulaire pour se
rendre dans les pharmacies et obtenir
obtenir ces fameuses auto test gratuit
j'ai une adhérente qui m'a encore dit ce
matin j'ai dû payer les autotests donc
on a une désorganisation totale avec
évidemment plus cette succession de
protocole qui donne enfin qui nécessite
un temps d'adaptation à chaque fois et
de transmission aux familles donc on ne
peut que constater effectivement
l'état des lieux et et partager les
constats qui sont faits sur le lien
bertrand d'azur dans un communiqué le
snui pp 78 parle de maltraitance de la
part du ministre envers les personnels
et les élèves ces évolutions de
protocoles c'est le fait de ne pas
fermer les écoles comme certains peuvent
le demander
c'est tout simplement le fait de ne pas
prendre en compte la réalité et c'est à
dire que la réalité est extrêmement
complexe elle et elle est d'une certaine
façon tout à fait inédite est ce qu'on
aurait aimé c'est avoir un ministre qui
la prennent en compte pour ce qu'elle
est je vais vous donner un exemple
qu'elle est à la préoccupation notre
ministre en ce moment c'est d'animer un
colloque sur le wiki sema la sorbonne et
d'autre part c'est de faire en sorte que
les évaluations de cp se déroule mois de
janvier qui peut croire que les
évaluations cp vont se dérouler dans de
bonnes conditions
sachant que c'est ce que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure au monde et est à une 5ème
semaine de de travail tout à fait en
pointillés et vouloir à tout prix que
les évaluations passe maintenant c'est
maltraiter les professeurs qui qui
savent très bien qu'ils n'ont pas pu
faire tout ce qu'ils auraient dû faire à
cette époque de l'année et c'est
maltraiter les enfants qui eux mêmes
n'ont pas pu avoir l'enseignement hawk
eye is endroit et si c'est simplement
pour faire un constat d'échec ou pour
pointer que certains fr certains enfants
sont absents on n'a pas besoin de faire
des évaluations de cp voilà tout ça
c'est de la maltraitance caractérisée
c'est ce à quoi s'applique d'autres
ministres depuis des années c'est à dire
plutôt que de prendre en compte les
choses telles qu'elles sont il fait en
sorte que la réalité devienne ce qu'il
pense mais ça n'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne je vais vous donner un autre
exemple ça fait depuis le début que nous
demandons à ce qu'il y ait des des tests
des parents des des appareils pour
mesurer le taux de co2 qui la seule
façon de savoir si l'aération est
satisfaisante dans les locaux scolaires
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée il ya à
peu près 1000 écoles dans les yvelines
ça fait 200 euros par part à pareille ça
fait deux cent mille euros pour les
yvelines sachant que notre ministre a
vendu 75 millions à son budget au mois
de décembre et 200 millions l'année
précédente donc si vraiment ils
voulaient soucier de faire en sorte que
les choses fonctionnent bien dans les
écoles ils seraient au plus près de ceux
dont les écoles les enfants et les
parents ont besoin est absolument pas de
ce qu'ils sont ses préoccupations et de
son calendrier qui comme tout le monde
doit prendre en compte la réalité mais
c'est pas la façon dont fonctionne notre
ministre et c'est en cela qu'il est
particulièrement magne traitant pour
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
cécile guilbert et elle ça fait aussi
partie des demandes de l'apep ce genre
de matériel peut être aussi des masques
ffp2 ou plus de masques chirurgicaux
pour le personnel alors
moi je effectivement en tant que
représentants de parents d'élèves ne
m'exprimerai pas pour ce que souhaitent
les enseignants mais pour autant en tant
que parent dont on a envie que nos
enseignants puissent enseigner de façon
suivie
et en toute sécurité
à nos enfants donc effectivement on a
bien des limites
de la communication ministérielle qui
vient qui vient vraiment au bout
puisqu'on ne peut que constater que les
moyens de protection individuelle et
collective ne sont pas mis en place ces
derniers mois pourquoi effectivement là
là alors que les
comment les recherches scientifiques
nous ont amené ces deux tout au long de
ces derniers mois a prouvé que la
contamination se faisait par aérosol
isation c'est-à-dire par transmission
dans l'air pourquoi effectivement on
n'appuie pas les moyens de protection
sur sur l'ensemble de cette de cette
caractéristique à savoir effectivement
des capteurs de co2 dans les classes
en ce qui nous concerne nous à conflans
sainte honorine on en a fait la demande
pour les écoles primaires à monsieur le
maire puisque effectivement c'est de la
compétence des communes des conseils
départementaux pour les collèges ou des
conseils régionaux pour pour les lycées
parce qu'il faut aussi parler du
secondaire est donc clairement
l'aller les moyens ce ne sont pas
compris à la hauteur de l'urgence qu'il
ya dans les dents dans les classes donc
on n'a toujours rien sachant mois par
ailleurs je déplore quand même que
la législation de ventilation fins de
diagnostic de ventilation ne soient pas
mises en oeuvre on a une législation qui
date de 2018 2018 les collectivités
locales auraient dû faire des
diagnostics de qualité de l'air vous
pouvez aller chercher les informations
sur le site du ministère de la
transition écologique on a quand même un
retard qui s'est accumulé et on le paye
un petit peu aujourd'hui donc et je moi
je me demande où en est le quoi qu'il en
coûte on nous a parlé pendant des mois
du quoi qu'il en coûte
pour les entreprises ce qui est très
bien évidemment mais où est le quoi
qu'il en coûte pour l'éducation
nationale et pour nos enfants
alors que on n'a pas de moyens et de
mise en oeuvre par les collectivités
locales de ses moyens de contrôle on n'a
pas non plus de moyens de remplacement
on voit bien que les classes aujourd'hui
sont fermées parce que il n'y a pas de
remplaçants et là je là aussi je réitère
ce que je disais où est la limite on
voit bien les limites de la
communication ministérielle
on nous parle enfin moi à chaque fois
que j'entends les télécommunications
dans la presse je ne peux que me dire
mémé ou ville monsieur le ministre on
n'en vit pas dans le même pays c'est pas
possible donc là on
a on arrive vraiment à 1.2
d'incompréhension totale par les famines
de ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'institution muriel dossier c'est un
sentiment partagé par la fcpe ça ce
notamment au niveau national à la fcpe
demande ait aussi des tests salivaires
en milieu scolaire qui serait moins
invasif que les tests pcr les
antigénique dont vous avez rappelé le
protocole qui a été allégé par le
premier ministre le 10 janvier dernier
tout à fait on partage ses réclamations
des masques gratuits parce que ces
masques ont un coût pour les parents
c'est des problématiques aussi que les
parents ont donc et ce test salivaire
comme vous avez dit dans les écoles des
capteurs de co2 qui ne dépendent plus
des collectivités pour éviter les
inégalités territoriales une continuité
pédagogique réel est pas simple une
continuité paris lève une prise en
compte des réels apprentissage lors des
examens une prise en compte du mal être
des enfants qui souffrent depuis deux
ans tous confondus quel que soit quel
que soit l'âge du plus petit a essayé
aux étudiants sans le sait et puis un
recrutement surtout massif d'enseignants
et de personnel pour combler les
absences qui sont toujours présentes et
remplacement ne sont pas au rendez vous
justement les collectivités ont été
mentionné plusieurs fois des élus m
depuis quelques jours aussi en avant
leurs inquiétudes dans notre journal
d'hier le mardi 11 janvier le maire de
ville proche jean baptiste à monique
disait se questionner sur le jeu le
jusqu'au boutisme de l'ouverture des
écoles bertrand mesure les murs des
écoles élémentaires sont gérés par les
mairies vous pouvez échanger avec eux
alors écoutez c'est toujours la même
question
j'écoute et madame tout à leur parler de
la compétence des mairies mais il ya
aussi la compétence de l'employeur
l'employeur à une obligation de moyens
et de résultats dans la protection ses
salariés et en l'occurrence monsieur
blanc caire n'a rien fait pour les
protéger efficacement on a eu la
pantalonnade de la début du début de
pandémie où tous les ministres nous
affirmait que le masque ce ne servent à
rien cela fait depuis deux ans que nous
réclamons des masques chirurgicaux
dans les écoles parce que c'est le seul
moyen d'être effectivement bien le mieux
protégé possible on va finalement les
obtenir mais au bout d'une situation qui
est devenue cataclysmique il en est de
même madame évoqué tout à l'heure les
diagnostics qualité de l'air intérieur
ils ont été faits dans tous les
établissements que ce soit ceux du
second degré comme ceux du premier degré
c'est la croix et la bannière pour
obtenir les synthèses de céder le
diagnostic et d'autre part il n'a
absolument rien n'était fait pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air intérieur
ça aurait été pourtant un moyen de
prévention extrêmement efficace dans la
situation nous sommes actuellement mais
là une fois de plus le sauvage sous
investissement chronique dans
l'éducation comme d'ailleurs dans le la
santé produit les effets que l'on a vu
et on ne peut pas à la fois chérir les
causes dont on regrette les effets c'est
ce que fait en permanence de notre
ministre et son gouvernement il ya un
sous investissement chronique que
chronique qu'on peut évaluer à 1%
produit intérieur brut ce qui fait quand
même 20 milliards d'euros par an et
est ce ce sous investissement que ce
soit dans le bâti scolaire que ce soit
dans la qualité de l'air intérieur
que ce soit dans la dans les espaces de
vie des enfants et puis plus
généralement je dirais dans l'hygiène au
sein des établissements parce que
l'hygiène est quelque chose qui a
toujours été mis de côté dans les écoles
et les établissements et donc on se
retrouve on s'est retrouvé dans des
situations et on se retrouve dans des
situations où vous faire passer une
classe au nettoyage des mains bas ça
prend un temps infini parce qu'il n'ya
pas assez de rubina et ses dents tous et
tous ces éléments font que on est dans
une situation qui n'aurait pas
certainement été entièrement compensées
par ces éléments là mais qui au moins
manifesterait de l'intérêt qu'aurait
prise gouvernement pour améliorer la
situation des établissements scolaires
ça n'est pas le cas et on se retrouve
dans une situation très difficile
j'ajouterai sur les tests que avant les
vacances de noël la plupart des tests
qui ont été réalisés aux écoles ont
donné lieu à des résultats soit très
partiel soit beaucoup trop en retard
pour servir à quelque chose soit parfois
par l'absence de résultats c'est à dire
que même après dix quinze jours les
parents n'avaient pas eu de résultats le
système n'est pas calibré pour la
situation que nous avons actuellement
mais d'autres ministres n'a rien fait
pour essayer d'accompagner au mieux
cette situation et c'est pour ça qu'on
est actuellement dans un cadre qui est
très dommageable pour les enfants nous
nous sommes pour l'ouverture des écoles
mais et des établissements scolaires
mais encore faut-il qu'ils aient les
moyens pour faciliter cette ouverture
oui justement ça a été évoqué on a
beaucoup parlé de l'impact sanitaire je
vais rester avec vous monsieur mesure ce
que j'imagine que vous craignez
peut-être aussi un retard pédagogique
pour les élèves entre leur absence celle
des professeurs qui sont positifs ou
qu'à contacter ça va faire deux ans que
la crise dure vous parlez des
évaluations de cp
le conte la continuité pédagogique
souffre aussi en ce moment
alors écoutez les enfants sont assez
fortement
concernée par tous ces éléments là il ya
des enfants qui skie dans le psychisme a
souffert au travers des différents
éléments de confinement nous avons des
parents inquiets de la situation et
l'inquiétude des parents n'est pas
quelque chose de satisfaisant pour des
enfants en pleine croissance nous avons
également eu tous ces problèmes de
remplacement qui en fait que c'est ce
que je disais là depuis cinq semaines on
est dans une situation d'enseignement
extrêmement partiel j'ajouterai que la
continuité pédagogique vanté par notre
ministre n'a jamais été que que miroir
aux alouettes parce que il aurait fallu
que l'ensemble du système et les moyens
d'assurer cette continuité pédagogique
sauf que notre ministre ne s'en est pas
soucié pas plus après 2000 confinement
qu'après les autres il a toujours joué
le fait qu'il n'y aurait pas de deuxième
vague puis de troisième vague puis d'un
quatrième vague et ainsi de suite et
maintenant on est dans une situation où
le défaut d'anticipation et est
manifeste et il tentera de faire
s'écrouler le système
c'est un sentiment partagé par les
parents d'élèves je vous donner la
parole à toutes les deux qui veut
débuter madame rétais ribes et madame
beaufils
oui
c'est un sentiment partagé effectivement
je reviendrai sur en abordant la
question du secondaire parce
qu'effectivement on voit les
conséquences au niveau des écoles bien
sûr du primaire mais on sait où on voit
aussi les conséquences au niveau du
secondaire et des classes qui prépare
les examens je pense en particulier à la
troisième à la première et à la
terminale et aussi à
enseignement professionnel et donc on
voit quand même que il ya une énorme des
organisations des cours ces dernières
ces dernières semaines en particulier
depuis la rentrée de janvier
évidemment la continuité pédagogique je
suis parfaitement d'accord
c'est un c'est une femme elle ne se fait
que à la mesure d'aider des cours qui
sont envoyées aux élèves comme quand
n'importe quel élève est malade de
n'importe quelle maladie
voilà il n'y a pas de y'a pas de
continuité pédagogique plus que ça
effectivement ça veut dire que l'élève
rattrape à la maison recopie c'est court
mais ne bénéficie pas de l'apport du
professeur qui n'est pas évidemment en
mesure de faire cours à la fois en
distanti elle est à la fois en
présentiel donc là aussi on à
la communication ministérielle
touche-touche ac a ses limites les
parents sont très inquiets de ce point
de vue là de ce qui se passe ces
derniers temps et je suis aussi
sur la même longueur d'onde sur la
question de la continuité de l'ouverture
des classes on est évidemment enfin je
pense que tout le monde est favorable à
l'ouverture des écoles mais dans quelles
conditions donc là on a derrière une
question de moyens qui n'est qu'il ne
qui ne permet pas que l'objectif soit
atteint par ailleurs je voudrais aussi
soulevé la question de la 2de de
l'articulation de l'ensemble de la crise
sanitaire on a c'est difficile pour les
parents d'entendre que ce ce que c'est à
eux de prendre en charge les tests que
c'est les acteurs sur le terrain qui
doivent se faire leur affaire de
l'ensemble du protocole alors qu'on voit
qu'au niveau collectif il n'y a pas de
prise en compte il n'y a pas de moyens
qui est mise en oeuvre donc en fait on
se retrouve à une gestion qui est
dévolue aux individus et non pas à la
collectivité alors qu'il faudrait que ce
soit équitablement réparti pour que les
uns dû se semble quand même dans leurs
efforts soutenus par la collectivité et
là je pense qu'effectivement il ya un
déséquilibre qui fait que
la machine ne peut pas continuer de dans
cet état là madame vous fait c'est ce
que vous souhaitez apporter le point de
vue de la fcpe rajouter quelque chose
je dirais que la fcpe a toujours voulu
garder les écoles ouvertes en it here
c'est très important pour
la sbe pour l'organisation des parents
également et puis on a encore des
protocoles c'est quand même incroyable
que des coteaux profs des protocoles
sont mis en place sans tenir compte des
difficultés qui assure sur le terrain
des autotests inexistant parcours du
combattant pour faire un test une queue
de
1h30 2h pour devant un laboratoire
pas plus tard qu'hier les gens sont
dehors en plein froid c'est juste
inadmissible
monsieur mesures je vais terminer avec
vous donc le mouvement du 13 janvier
devrait être très suivie selon les
premières estimations que vous que votre
syndicat a donné
j'imagine que l'intersyndicale se donne
la possibilité de continuer le mouvement
ensuite
il est de voir si on peut avoir un
interlocuteur raisonnable en face de
nous ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement et puis ça dépendra aussi
de l'évolution de la situation
l'objectif ce n'est pas de fermer les
écoles et de mettre l'ensemble de la
société en difficulté l'objectif c'est
d'arriver à des conditions de travail
pour tous les membres de la communauté
éducative qui soit autant que possible
congruent est compatible avec la
situation
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas le il
n'y a pas de dialogue je rappellerai
simplement que
les collègues ont appris en
téléchargeant ou en payant l'article du
parisien libéré dimanche soir de
décembre ce que serait le protocole du
lendemain notre ministre si on veut
savoir ce qu'ils pensent et ce qu'il
souhaite mettre en place on est on a
plus de chance en écoutant bfm tv où on
regarde dans les articles de journaux
que en regardant notre messagerie
professionnelle cela doit cesser et nous
devons pouvoir avoir un dialogue
constructif avec les parents les
collectivités locales qui sont très
impliqués dans ce dans ce parcours là et
de façon à ce qu'on puisse faire au
mieux dans les circonstances actuelles
mais encore faut-il là encore je le
répète qu'il n'y ait pas déni
systématique de la réalité
je vous propose que nous concluons sur
ces mots 7,8 société merci à nos invités
de s'être rendus disponibles merci aux
téléspectateurs de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau temps de discussion et bien sûr
d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]